the two more things I had to show you
are both under this heading of compound
functions which is when we have a
function of a function which is the
whole idea of inverses right remember we
looked at this we said until the other
end by definition if there's some
function f and some inverse F inverse
then if you take the function of the
universe you should get back your
original value ok this would be true for
all values of x if you're in verse
existed for all values of x but you can
see with these guys we've had to do like
tricky things with the domain
restrictions right so let's have a look
at this which I get with water right ok
we're going to do all at once sign of
sine inverse then we're going to do
cause of cos inverse and then we're
going to do 10 of 10 immers ok so let's
think about each of it what we are
expecting is something like this right
the sign the sign of us they sort of
ought to cancel each other out but what
we're going to do is watch for the range
restrictions and domain restrictions
that come with each one ok so friendly
have a look at sine inverse of X first
ok because you always got to go to start
me inside and then you go up what's the
domain restriction on sine inverse of X
we just kind of stated it over here it's
negative 15
okay so therefore if I put in two or a
hundred or negative fifteen sine inverse
is just going to say forget it go home I
don't exist outside there because the
amplitude of side is restricted me here
right so therefore this whole thing is
going to be equal to this but only in
here does that make sense so in other
words I can say this is equal to X in
this restricted domain negative one to
one okay so this is a really easy crap
to draw this is nice it doesn't even
need you very large do so have a nice
square set of axes and I know what this
looks like and I just want to draw this
part of that graph so it's going to look
very simply like that that's what why
does X looks like but it has a start and
it has an end
that's all there is to her
okay when we go to college cos inverse
how is this different in how is it
similar data I should ask the question
has a similar first what ways are
similar what things are single
it's still going to be equal to X
because you're still compounding the
same kind of a function and it's inverse
right something's still expecting
something like this what else is seeing
very good center main restriction this
thing still only exists from negative 1
to 1 you can see it my green wrapper
dinner so therefore the same restriction
is true so therefore this is also true
okay so in fact going from here to here
nothing has changed
that seems to me we but just for the
sake of completeness and because it
won't take you very long let's draw this
graph because it will help set up for us
and appreciate the fact that something
else is happening here so let's just
quickly draw this segment
okay okay Joe one more time right what's
the same and what's different what's the
same
three times right I've been doing this
I've done again and again and again it's
the composite all one function and it's
inverse I'm expecting that this should
look like X right ah but at last I've
had a difference right because this guy
yeah it's different to these i canna set
to any value of x you like right because
you guys remember the graph it looks
like this right and crucially it's got
its errors it's happy to go as far as
you like so therefore because this
exists for all real values of x
therefore this also exists
done and because there's no restriction
I don't need to say anything okay so
that was the simplest graph in the
hardest topic ever this guy is just a
regular graph y equals x within their
modification
ok